the associated press which has
long not only given in to political
correctness and woke language but has
in some ways led the charge in the past
they
are now banning the people who follow
the ap guidelines from using the term
mistress
well it's a mistress a mistress is a
lady who's sleeping with a married man
right
no no longer the ap style book says
quote
don't use the term mistress for a woman
who's in a long-term sexual relationship
with
and is financially supported by a man
who is married to someone else
instead use an alternative like
companion
friend or lover on first reference
and provide additional details later now
you see the problem with uh
friend say i am friends with andrew
clavin
and andrew clavin is a married man i do
not want there to be any confusion
about the nature of our relationship so
you've got these very vague words friend
companion they're really they don't tell
you anything
then you've got a more specific word
lover but they're all sorts of lovers
people can have lovers in a perfectly
above-board way or at least relatively
above board way
but when you're sleeping with a married
man that's not above board that's wrong
that's sinful you shouldn't be doing
that sort of thing
but we're not allowed to use the term
mistress whatever term you end up using
is going to acquire
negative connotations this is called the
euphemism treadmill stephen pinker who
is no conservative but he's a harvard
professor
he pointed this out a number of years
ago now
the idea of the euphemism treadmill is
that
radicals want to deny harsh realities so
they sugarcoat them
with euphemisms however
over time the realities remain and so
the reality is because they continue to
assert themselves
will recolor the euphemism that people
add to it so whatever words you're going
to make up for mistress it's going to
take on
a negative connotation this is true for
people who
have mental deficiencies in initially
terms like simpleton or idiot or [ __ ]
were or [ __ ] for that matter were
you might say euphemistic they were
terms they were trying to describe
in a way that was relatively polite and
inoffensive
this deficiency but because the
deficiency is not
particularly desirable you know it's a
it's
a by definition it's a deficiency over
time
it takes on a negative connotation and
so rather than just trying to
be compassionate to people who have not
just mental deficiencies but all sorts
of divisions and we've all got something
instead what these uh linguistic
verbal hygienists want to do these
cultural radicals want to do
is just come up with a new term and they
think that's going to change the
underlying reality it doesn't really
happen
and i don't want to just strawman the
ap's argument here
the ap goes a little bit further they
say quote
we added this guidance last year it's
not new we understand it's problematic
that the alternative terms fall short
like suggesting that
if i am friends with andrew clavin that
implies something that nobody wants to
think about
but they write we felt that was better
than having
one word for a woman and none for the
man and implying that the woman was
solely responsible for the affair
well it doesn't imply that the woman is
solely responsible for the affair there
are all sorts of terms for a man
who cheats on his wife with some woman
you call him a cat you can call him an
adulterer you can call him a womanizer i
said oh
plenty of terms for that but you're
right it's not the same term
it's different you wouldn't call a man
who's in a similar kind of relationship
a mistress but the words are different
not because of the unfairness of our
language and the patriarchy
the words are different because the
sexes are different
and the sexes are very different in this
regard
very rarely are you going to find a
young man
who is in a who's who is a kept man from
an
older woman you know he's pursuing this
older woman who's got a family but she's
cheating on her husband
with this younger man and it's an
illicit relationship but you know she
keeps them up in
a nice apartment or something like that
that's just not how it works
men and women have different
relationships to
sex their sexual desires are of a
different character
the the significance of sex to them is
of a different nature
the the things that men would do
if they were not hemmed in by the moral
order and our marital vows
sexually are different than the
behaviors that women would
engage in feminism seeks to deny this
leftism broadly seeks to deny this
because they cannot stand
the difference between men and women
it's why they're so obsessed now with
redefining
men to become women and women to become
men and and defining sex is a social
construct
but there actually is a difference and
that's why there are different words
and you can try to change the words but
it's just not going to change
that reality stop don't go anywhere
don't i know you were about to
don't before you go you gotta smash
the like button you gotta subscribe
youtube does not wanna be regularly
serving up this kind of content okay not
totally in accord
with the sort of things that they think
so do that you click
you click you're good i'll see you next
[Music]
[Music]
time